[Music]
[Applause]
this
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right guys me and nate we're here in
dale huddle tennessee and i'm here with
kenny mack and rick slinker and they're
pro staffers with the carp bait company
world classic baits and we are going to
tear up some big old carp and we're
going to be camping it's going to be
awesome now if you guys want to do this
too i'll put their information in the
video description below and maybe just
maybe they'll take you on one of these
trips too it's like the d-day invasion
holy mackerel
all right see you guys all right thank
you very much
oh
well check it out guys we got this whole
point of land all to ourselves we're
going to be fishing and camping for
three days and two nights
this is gonna be awesome dale hollow
tennessee is one of the top three carp
fishing destinations in north america it
is an amazing place and people come from
all over to fish for the massive mirror
carp and common carp they're here in
this reservoir so we're gonna get our
rods and reels set up and start fishing
and then set up camp
all right i'm going to use a lot of
different baits to catch these fish but
one of my favorite baits is panko
strawberry jello and sweet corn it makes
what we call a pack bait i'll show you
what i mean
[Applause]
so i got a bunch of cans of panko
breadcrumbs
then i got a big thing of strawberry
gelatin mix or jello mix
now we add some sweet corn
you look you just take this ball of
jello and you mold it around
your wet lead and then on my hook i've
got this little plastic corn shove that
right inside
we're good to go
well because there's two of us i brought
two sets of rods one set is my european
carp fishing gear and the other are the
catfish and carp series whisker seeker
rods these are my own signature series
rods named after my catfishing carp
youtube channel and uh we're gonna try
to catch some big old 30 pound carp on
them hey what'd you find
oh yeah look at these little fossils
nathan found these little fossils
i'm using bait on most of my rods but on
this one i'm gonna actually use a carp
lure this is called a zig right
two of these rods have zig bugs and one
of them i'm gonna use boiled feed corn
we're gonna chum a bunch of it out and
then throw our bait right on top of the
pile of chump
i got three bite alarms
and these will tell me if any fish come
biting along so i can go set up my camp
while keeping in the air out for fish
uh
[Music]
all right we got the fishing gear out we
got camp set up what's the first thing
nathan wants to do
you look for fossils too
look at all these fossils
[Music]
for lunch i'm gonna eat this heat and
serve japanese curry i love this stuff
daddy
heat and serve japanese curry and
boiling bag rice
we can't be camping in tennessee without
eating moon pies
there you go
it's like a chocolate covered
marshmallow cookie sandwich
oh
man
oh
i am so tired oh i just might take a
little nap i'm exhausted and i can hear
my body alarms so
something bites it'll wake me up
fish fish fake tayden fish come on
we got a fish
nathan i need a net he was running for
the other side of the reservoir what
time i got here
would you like to reel him in okay you
got him
he's he's big keep like you got to keep
that rod up in the air like that you
like that you gotta oh oh i can see him
over here
see him okay they're brought up in the
air nathan up high up high
you don't have any shoes on
[Music]
okay let me go get him untangled okay
there we go he's on
that is a big old fat common carpet yeah
he doesn't have any
he's got a perfect tail on him you ready
to see how much he weighs yeah
[ __ ] him up
he is 21 pounds 21 pounds
oh are you ready to let him go
nathan high five buddy
good times that was awesome ate a little
food
took a little nap
woke up nathan landed a 21 pound carp ah
this is my kind of camping well it's 4
p.m and we just landed our first fish i
expect it only to get better man i've
just been starting to see some big fish
jumping out here so
i think it's gonna get pretty exciting
you guys got a fish
i'll take it
oh
popped off
so nathan what do you think so far has
this been a fun trip
yeah
it's a lot nicer than sleeping on
buffalo hides it's six degree weather
isn't it
yeah
where he didn't finish his dinner
oh this sure is pretty out here we're
having a good time
well it's about seven o'clock and the
sun's setting and uh man i'm just on
pins and needles we we could get into
some big carp any second now
but uh i'm gonna get the fire going and
i'm gonna make some dinner we got some
shish kebabs ready for dinner tonight
and i'm looking forward to that
so
[Music]
all right there's one chicken and one
beef and wrapped in bacon
and
let's blew up this is pretty awesome
pens pants pants
there's some weirdness going on over
here
yeah and daddy if you want to think like
this
it's a white hole
a simulator it's scary
all right there you go four of them
daddy i'm doing this to make you a
little fatter
i don't need any help with that
go on my bed i wanted to be in my bed
you got your blankie and my minions you
got your mimi you got a problem
all right
there we go
it's a beautiful full day ahead of us
[Music]
so
[Music]
like breakfast in bed here
oh hello
[Applause]
look at that
right there
fake piece of corn right there in the
corner mouth
okay
31 pounds
oh
big
oh yeah
that is a nice
nice fish 31 pound mirror
well that was fun i just came over to
check out my rods and i actually saw the
carp hit that one before the alarm set
off well a 31 pound mirror i think
that's the biggest mirror carp i've ever
caught my previous record was 28 pounds
i think
so not too bad those mirror carp are a
lot more rare here in the u.s
so they're kind of special
oh
look at that
look at that that's a hit right there
get the net there you go
perfect net job
another one on the ponco bait with the
fake corn that's been the ticket all
three fish oh yeah look at this
[Music]
nice 19-pound mirror carp
he is spunky so he's this one's gonna
fight more than the others
all right
hold on wait wait wait wait oh there he
goes
got some clean dry clothes now let's uh
get that rod back at the water catch
more fish
episode
he ran away super fast if you guys like
this sort of thing you want to see a lot
more fishing videos or if you want to
see how we do our rigs or how i make my
baits or gear reviews or any of that
stuff check out my other youtube channel
the catfish and carp youtube channel
i've been doing that one for seven years
and have over 500 videos on carp fishing
catfishing and other types of fishing
i'll put a link down in the video
description below if you want to check
that out
yeah yeah yeah yeah come here come here
come here dude grab it grab it dude grab
that one the one that's spinning yeah
so you got to keep that rod up in the
air
that's a that's that's a big fish buddy
hey looks like he's a meal
hey
yeah
oh we got it
oh
this is a big fish
i love that corn
they're all hitting that corn
36 and a half pounds
nathan is that awesome yeah
congratulations buddy
oh
look at this fish
there he goes
whoa that was a big fish now that's
nathan's new personal best and nathan's
really happy because he just tied his
older brother's personal best
i'll tell you what guys i love these
rods these are the whisker seeker
catfish and carp series rods they're
named after my youtube channel because i
helped design these
and this is exactly what i designed them
for catching catfish and carp this is a
great carbon fiber rod i'm going to put
a link in the video description where
you can buy them hey nathan
congratulations your new personal best
yeah and you tied
good
tommy
all right got all the rods rebated and
spots chummed up i'm gonna hang out and
watch some more movie this is my kind of
fishing
this is a british carp fishing bivvy
it's a tent specifically designed for
carp fishermen one of the things that
makes this specifically for carp fishing
is that the door can be velcroed shut so
that in the middle of the night if your
alarms go off you can
rip open the door and bust out really
quick so you don't get burned but i'm
gonna
yeah
as much as nathan loves top ramen i am a
sucker for a good curry so
we're doing that again
like your ramen yeah
oh
this is nice i've been furious
i have all right nathan you hungry yeah
what do you want to eat tonight
steak
why is that
[Music]
you know nathan we probably shouldn't
eat just steak we should we got kind of
like a balanced meal don't you think
yeah how about some captain crunch oh
look it's got vitamins
we're eating healthy aren't we
yeah i'll tell you what guys i love
these cots they're a memory foam caught
with adjustable legs so you can always
level the bed and the sleeping bag that
goes with them straps to the cot so when
you toss and turn or jump out of bed at
night
your sleeping bag doesn't come flying
off the cot if you're in north america
and you want to buy some of this
european style fishing and camping gear
check out bigcarptackle.com
hey oh
fish nathan fish
[Music]
praise it raise it raise it raise it
you got him
he's heavier than he looks
24 pounds
look at that beauty
all right let's get him in the water
there we go
they're just monster carp in here i mean
the average is like the low 20s i think
the smallest fish we got was 19 pounds
that's insane
it's just an absolutely insane average
their private carp fishing lakes
in europe and england
that would kill for these types
of carp numbers
and they're just here wild in the u.s
and hardly anyone fishes for it
that strawberry ponca and sweet corn is
just doing a wonderless job
just gonna keep at it
well the sun's setting on day two and i
got all the rods rebated and
repositioned
i think we're gonna be in for an
interesting night we got a good feeling
about tonight we're just kind of sitting
here and relaxing
once it gets real dark we're gonna eat
some moon pies and hang out a little bit
maybe watch a movie because you gotta
eat moon pies under the full moon
here's your pillow
okay
uh we're gonna go hit the sack and
maybe we'll pick up a fish in the middle
of night otherwise i'll see you guys in
the morning
we got who we got
beautiful 23.5 pound
card
there we go well that was my 5 am
wake-up call
but i was going to see if i can go back
to bed it's cold and wet out here
yep
oh
good morning
29 and a half pounds
what a beauty
all right let's get her back in
there we go
he just picked at it picked at it and
picked that
woke me up like twice before he finally
grabbed it and ran
here's a little trick when you make it a
cylinder instead of a sphere
and then put your hook right in the
bottom that way when it lands
it'll land like this
and instead of landing with your hook
buried underneath it
all right i got all the rods baited up i
think i'm going to build a little bit of
a campfire
because i could really use something to
warm me up
so i'm gonna have myself some breakfast
here
you get this ultra pasteurized milk it
doesn't really need to get refrigerated
if you're gonna use it in a couple days
and on a cold morning like this
tastes perfect
well it's 8 30 and nathan hasn't stirred
so i think i better go wake him up
hey you well i've got a warm fire for
you oh this has been pretty amazing but
it is time to go home
we got a couple hours before our buddies
are going to come with the boat and pick
us up
so uh there's our getting packed
here comes a ride
nathan got a new personal best i got a
new personal best for miracar it's not a
bad trip not a bad trip at all
if you guys want to do this too make
sure to check out rick's website i'll
put a link down in the video description
below okay
thanks guys
oh all right should we go home see mama
nathan did you have a good trip
hopefully you guys enjoyed watching this
video as much as we enjoyed filming it
if you want to see more travel and
adventure and camping videos from the
outdoor boys youtube channel don't
forget to click subscribe we put out new
videos every saturday morning and if you
guys want to see lots of fishing videos
don't forget to check out my other
channel the catfish and carp youtube
channel with lots of tips and tutorials
on how to catch carp and catfish and
we'll see you guys next saturday morning
every saturday morning
[Music]
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button so you'll get
notifications thanks for watching